What will happen,
the Joe Rogan experience,
I would have never,
I knew what it meant.
I've done ADR.
Yep.
I did it like fear factor.
Like every episode I had to do ADR,
it was the worst.
Why'd you,
because you were just mispronouncing names or you weren't,
it was usually because they wanted a titan segments.
I'd like,
you know,
we would film for three days and we'd have to slam that down to 44 minutes.
And so sometimes you needed brevity or sometimes they needed clarification for
certain things.
Like,
like we would explain the rules to them like very specifically and they would
have to read these rules and it took a long time.
But then like sometimes in the moment,
like on television,
you wouldn't explain it as clearly.
Like while we're filming like we would,
we'd show them like this is what you have to do,
this is what you have to start here.
You go from here to there.
But sometimes when you would want to put it on TV,
you want to be more precise or more concise.
Yeah.
So I would,
every fucking week I have to do ADR.
I hated it.
You did.
It seems like it would be fun,
like fear factor,
but just ADR seems like easy.
It's relaxed.
You're just in the booth.
Yeah.
It was boring.
No,
no,
I didn't like it.
No,
no.
The Fun thing about fear factor was when the checks came,
that was a fun time.
And then when Nice people,
one,
that was fun too.
Yeah,
those things were fun,
but really that was,
that was a great job,
but it was a job.
It was like a job,
but like,
you know,
if you had a great,
like,
yeah,
I really like working here,
whereas you don't really say that about stand up.
No,
I don't think about it as a job.
It's just fucking fun.
It's awesome.
Oh,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
It's a get to do.
Yeah.
I get to do.
That's my new thing is like get to do versus have to do.
Yeah.